[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم شهدت الدوحه توقيع حكومه الخرطوم
وحركه العدل والمساواه السودانيه اتفاقا
نهائيا للسلام في دارفور خطوه تلقفتها
اطراف معنيه بالصراع في الاقليم بردود فعل
شديده التباين نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين مضامين الاتفاق وما اعقبه من
قراءات متباينه لهذا
الحدث وقدره الاتفاق على جذب اطراف جديده
ما يؤدي لارساء سلام
مستدام خطوه لابد منها لاحلال الاستقرار
ودفع عجله التنميه تحت هذا العنوان وقعت
حركه العدل والمساواه السودانيه على اتفاق
سلام النهائي مع حكومه الخرطوم في مبادره
سرعان ما جوبهت برفض وانتقاد فصائل مسلحه
اخرى في الاقليم لم ترى في هذا الاتفاق
سوى التفاف على مشاكل دفور لصالح نظام
البشير يراد من هذه اللحظه ان تكون خطوه
في طريق طويل وشق نحو السلام المنتظر في
دارفور اخيرا وقعت حركه العدل والمساواه
السودانيه بقياده محمد بشر على وثيقه
السلام دارفور التي رات النور في الدوحه
في يوليو
2011 اول الموقعين حينها كانت حركه
التحرير والعداله برئاسه التجان السيسي
انخراط حركتين فقط في مسار السلام لا يكفي
لاحلال في منطقه لم تتخلص من اسباب الحرب
التي اندلعت عام 2003 ولا من ماسيه
القائمه حتى اللحظه تضم خريطه التمرد في
دارفور عده حركات ابرزها خمس منها اثنتان
قبله وثقه الدوحه ليستمر الخلاف بين
الخرطوم وحركات جيش تحرير السودان جناح
عبد الواحد نور وجيش تحرير السودان جناح
مني اركو مناوي والعدل والمساواه برئاسه
جبريل ابراهيم وثقه سلام دارفور هي خريطه
طريق كان يفترض ان يسير عليها جميع
الفرقاء في الاقليم الواقع غرب السودان
تتطرق اهم بنودها الى قضايا العداله
والمصالحه والتعويضات واقتسام الثروه
والسلطه والنازحين ومحاسبه المجرمين تبادل
الاتهامات والتشكيك في نوايا كل طرف اخر
تطبيق الخريطه ومعها تاجلت مشاريع التنميه
واعاده الاعمار الموعوده في الاقليم فقد
ادت الحرب التي اتهم فيها عناصر الجنجويد
بارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه بحق
السودانيين غير العرب الى مقتل ما لا يقل
عن 300 الف شخص تعترف الخرطوم ب 100 الف
فقط نزح بسببها ووفق الامم المتحده مليون
و400 الف شخص استبق بعضهم بدايه اعمال
مؤتمر المانحين في الدوحه بمظاهرات في عده
مناطق من الاقليم للتنديد بانعدام الامن
وبينما يسعى المؤتمر الدولي للمانحين الى
جمع اكثر من سبعه مليارات دولار لمساعده
الاقليم يرى بعض الفوريين ان الاولويه هي
اقناع جيع الفصائل المسلحه بوضع السلاح
والانخراط في عمليه سياسيه دائمه وليست
مؤقته لان ما الفه السودانيون من
السياسيين والمتمردين والى عهد قريب هو
نقد
العهود ولمناقشة
حركه العدل
والمساواه سيد علي وفي اولا ما الذي
اقنعكم
بالنهايه للتوقيع على هذا الاتفاق اي فارق
يصنعه هذا الاتفاق في مسار السلام في
دارفور بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نحنا في
البدايه يعني بنقدم صوت شكر لدوله قطر
اميرا وشعبا على الدور الكبير الحقيقه
اللي لعبته في اطار العمليه السلميه وايضا
نشكر الوساطه والمنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه المهتمه بالقضيه في
دارفور الدافع يعني احنا حقيقه في حركه
العدل والمساواه وقعنا سلام على الحكومه
السودانيه ونعتقد انه هذا السلام سياتي
بالخير
وخير والاستقرار
والتنميه لاهل السودان واهل دارفور بصفه
خاصه وخاصه اهلنا في في النزوح واللجوء
لذلك نعتقد انه هذا
السلام سيحقق تنميه حقيقيه وسيحقق استقرار
بعد قتال دام ع سنوات ا يعني من الناحيه
المضموني على مستوى المحتوى يعني ما هو او
ما هي البنود التي ترون انها تستجيب
لمطالب
الاقليم نعم
احنا تلقينا دعوه من الوساطه المشتركه
واتينا الى الدوحه وتناقشنا حقيقه في في
خمس ملفات
اساسيه بتحوي وثيقه الدوحه والخمسه ملفات
بنفتكر انها هي دي الاشكالات اللي بطرحها
واقع دارفور تناقشنا في ملف العداله
والمصالحه وتناقشنا
حول
تقاسم
الثروه والسلطه وايضا تناقشنا حول
التعويضات فنعتقد انه ما ما اضفناه
للوثيقه فيشكل حقيقه يعني الاضافه حقيقيه
لاتفاق الدوحه وبنفتكر انه
الان مساله السلام هي اصبحت مطلب اهل
دارفور
ومطلب لكل المتضررين حقيقه من الحرف في
دارفور ونفتكر انه بتوقيع حركه العدل
والمساواه للعمليه او للسلام في المرحله
دي ب نفتكر انها مهمه جدا جدا وبنفتكر
انها بتسم في الاستقرار وفي نفس الوقت
بتكون فاتحه شهيه للمؤتمر لمؤتمر
المانحين الان المنعقد في الدوحه وحقيقه
يعني نامل انه المؤتمر برضو يؤدي او على
اقل تقدير ينجز الاهداف المرجوه بغرض انه
يسهم في في في عمليه الاعمار والتنميه في
دارفور سيد جبريل انتم لكم راي مخالف
تماما يقولون بان هذا الاتفاق هو قفز على
المشاكل الحقيقيه لدارفور كيف
ذلك شكرا جزيلا انا احب ان اصحح معلومه
غايه في الاهميه انه الاطراف او الطرف
الذي وقع بالامس على وثيقه
الدوحه هذا الطرف ليس بحركه العدل
المساواه السودانيه وانما مجموعه خرجت من
حركه العدد والمساواه السودانيه ربما يكون
عندها رغبه الالتحاق بنظام المؤتمر الوطني
او يكون عندها بعض التوجهات المحدده التي
تريد ان ان تلبيها بهذا الاتفاق
ولكن الحقيقه انه هذه المجموعه التي وقعت
هي ليست حركه العدد المساواه السودانيه
بقدر ما انه حركه العدل المساواه
السودانيه المعروف عنها واحنا كنا موجودين
في الدوحه هذه الحركه لا على المستوى
السياسي ولا على المستوى العسكري ولا على
كل المستويات هذه الحركه لم توقع على هذه
الوثيقه واحنا لم نوقع على هذه الوثيقه
لانه هذه الوثيقه وثيقه الدوحه او كلام من
هذا النوع بقدر ما انه المبررات كانت
منطقيه احنا تفاوضنا مع حكومه المؤتمر
الوطني في الدوحه لاكثر من ثلاث سنوات من
العام 2009 احنا كنا نتفاوض مع حكومه
المؤتمر الوطني تحت الضيافه القطريه وتحت
الوساطه المشتركه وكان هنالك جو من من قبل
وبيئه صالحه للحوار من قبل الدوله المضيفه
قطر ومن قبل الوساطه المشتركه ولكن للاسف
الشديد المؤتمر الوطني النظام الحاكم في
السودان كان يستخدم هذه المنابر التفاوضيه
ستخدمها لعلاقات العامه
ويستخدمها للكسب الوقت وغيره ولا يريد
النظام الحاكم في السودان مخاطبه القضايا
الرئيسيه ودائما النظام الحاكم في السودان
يختار طريق الانشقاقات ويختار طريق
التقسيم قوى المقاومه الثوريه
وتقسيم الاحزاب والقوى السياسيه ويختار
الطرف الاضعف للتوقيع معه في اتفاقيه لان
الحكومه السودانيه بعد ما توقع الاتفاق مع
الطرف الاضعف تريد ان تتنصل من تنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيات ولذلك تختار بعض الراغبين في
الالتحاق بالمؤتمر الوطني وتوفر لهم بعض
البيئه سواء كان في الدوحه او في غيره
ويوقعوا بازم حركه العدل المستوه
السودانيه ولكن الحقيقه انه هذه المجموعه
ليست حركه العدل وال المستوه السودانيه
وما اعتقد انه هذا الاتفاق سيضيف اي اضافه
فعليه في ارض الواقع لانه اولا هذا
الاتفاق لمم لم يخاطب القضايا الرئيسيه
والمساله الثانيه الاطراف الرئيسيه في
دارفور وفي السودان مثل حركه العدل
لمستواه السودانيه ذات البعد المعروف
والمواقف السياسيه المعروفه والقوى
العسكريه الاخرى لم توقع على هذا الاتفاق
ولذلك ما اعتقد انه هذا الاتفاق سيكون
باقل سوءا من الاتفاقيات الاخرى التي وقعت
سواء كان في الدوحه او في اي مكان اخر سيد
بشار يعني اذا اذا ما فهمت ضيفي سيد جبريل
انتم يعني بشكل او باخر تنتحل صفه يعني
مطبح الرئيسي هو المشاركه في مستويات
الحكم في السودان ولكن تنسون ان هناك
تجربه فاشله في السابق تجربه شراكه سياسيه
مع مع الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان
نعم هو كلام الاخ جبريل ادم بلال هو كلام
غير صحيح طبعا ومساله نحنا بننتقل شخصيه
ولا بندعي اننا حركه العدل والمساواه او
تسميته لنا مجرد مجموعه هو ده كلام غير
صحيح وكلام يعني بقالي فيه اكثر من اللازم
فا اخونا جبرين بلال والاخرين اللي معاه
بيعرفون من نحن واحنا كنا راس الحربه لما
كنا في العدل والمساواه الكل يشهد
العمليات في دارفور ولا سواء كانت امدرمان
ولا سواء كانت كل المعارك اللي دارتها
حركه العدل والمساواه احنا من كنا نقود
هذه الحركه واحنا من كنا نقود متحركات
واحنا من كنا يعني نخطط لعمليات العسكريه
صحيح انه الان في مجموعه صغيره جدا جدا
بقياده جبريل ابراهيم وهم ديل اصحاب مدرسه
تنظيميه واحده فكلهم اذا جيت مسكتهم
ملمومين هم يعني في
النهايه اصحاب مدرسه تنظيميه وعندهم مصالح
ممكن الارتباطات تنظيميه الان ما بتخليهم
مثلا يمشوا في في العمليه السلميه فهم
الان عباره عن جيش سياسي يعني احنا الان
موجودين على الارض والمساله دي احنا ما
محتاجين منها شهاده من اخونا جبريل بلال
وهو بيعرفنا كويس جدا جدا واحنا موجودين
اليوند بتعرف قوتنا على
الارض الاخوه الاخرين اللي بيحملوا السلاح
بيعرفوا احنا موجودين في الارض والان نحنا
موجودين ومنتشر في شمال دارفور وفي غرب
دارفور وفي جنوب دارفور اسال جبريل جبريل
ادم بلال قول انتم الان موجودين وين الان
نحنا بنعرف اماكنهم واحسن ما نقوله في
الاعلام واحسن ما نتكلم عن الملفات
واستدعاء الاخرين لانه العدل والمساواه
نحنا من من من صنع تاريخ العسكري جبرين
بلال وغيره هم عباره عن ناس رابطين كرتات
ولافين في عواصم الدول سيش ما عندهم اي
علاقه ما عندهم اي علاقه بالواقع الميداني
هم الان
سياسيا المساواه سياسيا ده شانهم انت تقول
هذا الكلام وغيرك ايضا يقول هذا الكلام
يعني هناك مشكله حقيقيه في موضوع
التمثيليه يعني لمشاكل واقليم دارفور
والراي العام داخل دارفور يعني هذا هذا
الاشكال مازال مطروحا الى حد الان كيف كيف
يمكن حسمه وسط هذا التشتت والتشرذم
والله حقيقه نحنا نعترف انه هناك يعني
انقسامات الشي المؤسف في في واقع الحركات
وده نتاج لانه ما في قياده يعني والدليل
على
ذلك وجودنا نحنا خارج اطار منظمه العدل
والمساواه القديمه يعني حقيقه كل القيادات
الان الموجوده في دارفور غير مؤهله لانها
تقود العمل الثوري في دارفور ولذلك اي
نحنا كثوار يعني ما دايرين الشرعيه من من
احد ولا بدينا لها اسم ان احنا اخذنا
شرعيتنا براس بندقيته والان بنفتكر ان
احنا الدوافع والاسباب الحقيقيه اللي
دفعتنا لحمل السلاح الان نحنا تناقشنا
وتراضينا
حول الاسباب دي وبنفتكر انه احنا السلام
اللي وقعنا ده حنقدر نفرضه على الارض وبعد
ذاك سواء كان جبريل ولا
غيره الميدان زي ما قالت الجماعه بيناتنا
نعم سيد جبريل
يعني انتم ايضا تقولون بان ما جرى هو من
قبيل المعالجه الجزئيه لمشاكل دارفور يعني
كيف ترون كليات الاشياء او او المعالجه
الكليه اين هي الحلقه المفقوده في في في
هذا الاسهال ان صح التعبير من الاتفاقات
الموقعه الى حد
الان الحلقه المفقوده الان في الازمه
السودانيه في دارفور هي الازمه السودانيه
بكلياتها والحلقه المفقوده انه حكومه
المؤتمر الوطني بدلا من الجلوس مع الاطراف
الرئيسيه صاحبه الشان التي يمكن ان ان
تساهم في انزال اي اتفاق على ارض الواقع
بدلا من مخاطبه والجلوس والتفاوض مع مثل
هذه الاطراف الرئيسيه الحكومه تلجا لجلوس
مع اطراف اصلا هي ما موجوده في ارض الواقع
هذه هي الحقيقه الاشكاليه الحقيقيه الان
انه حكومه المؤتمر الوطني يعني على سبيل
المثال للحصر هذه المجموعه التي وقعت هي
مجموعه مفصوله من حركه العدل لمستواه
السودانيه ومجموعه مبعده وكان جزء منهم تم
القاء القبض عليهم لارتباطات للشك في انهم
مرتبطين بالاجهزه الامنيه الحكوميه وانهم
بيعملوا لمصلحه جهاز الامن والمخابرات
والان ثبت الحقيقه انه هذه المجموعه هرولت
الى التوقيع مع حكومه المؤتمر الوطني ثبت
ما كان يقوله الاخرين انه هذه المجموعه هي
تعمل لمصلحه الحكومه السودانيه وهذه
المجموعه كلها الموجوده في الدوحه انا
اتحدى اي واحد فيهم ان كان اساسي عنصر
اساسي من الناس المؤسسين لحركه العدل
لمستوى السودانيه يعني كلهم هي مجموعه
القادمين الجدد الخارجين من حركه العدل
لمستواه السودانيه المتهرئ او المهرولين
الى حكومه المؤتمر وطني ما فيهم طرف اساسي
من حركه العدل والمساواه السودانيه الدنيا
كلها وحتى الوساطه القطريه في فتره من
الفترات كانت استضافت حركه العدل
والمساواه السودانيه ولا زالت علاقه حركه
العدل والمساواه السودانيه سواء كانت
بالوسيط القطري او بال الجامعه العربيه او
الوساطه المشتركه هي في علاقه تواصل وتعرف
هذه الوساطه اين حركه العدل لمستويات
السودانيه الاساسيه وكل هذه المجموعات هي
عباره عن فروع طيب ولطالما انه الحكومه
السودانيه او الوساطه المشتركه لم تخاطب
الجزور وال المؤسسات الرئيس صاحبه الشان
وبس لجت الى مخاطبه الفروع مخاطبه الفروع
لا يمكن ولا يعني باي صوره من الصور انها
تسا في ح حاله الاشكاليه الحقيقيه سنع
سنعود السودان والوساطه المشتركه سنعود
للنقاش مازال لدينا وقت فقط نتوقف عند
فاصل قصير نواصل بعدها مناقشه امكاني وسبل
اقناع الرافضين الذين هم انتم لاتفاق
الدوح بال الالتحاق به تفضلوا والبقى معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش المواقف من توقيع حركه العدل
والمساواه السودانيه اتفاق سلام نهائي مع
حركه الخرطوم سيد بشار على راي الرافضين
انتم الفروع وهم الاصول والنظام السوداني
الرسمي عرف كيف يراهن ربما على الحلقه
الاضعف في هذه الحركات المسلحه وبالتالي
فان هذا الاتفاق يصب في مصلحته اكثر من
مصلحه يعني المدافعين عن قضايا دارفور كيف
ترد وده كلام غير صحيح انا اعتقد انه
الكلام انه الفروع
وما والاصول اصلا يعني في العمل الثوري ما
اجريت انتخابات عشان يعرفوا من اللي عنده
قواعد ولا عنده جماهير ولا اللي عنده جيش
اكتر ولا غيره فذا كلام غير صحيح انا احنا
اعتقد انه احنا في حركه العدل والمساواه
نحنا القياده الميدانيه قاعدين موجودين
طيله العش سنين بقاتل في
دارفور والناس الموجودين الان القياده
العامه
وكل القيادات في حركه العدل والمساواه
السياسيه وفي قياداتها التشريعيه
الموجودين في الميدان انا اركز على الكلمه
دي الموجودين في الميدان الان احنا
ارتضينا خيار السلام الان الكلام عن انه
والله دي مجموعه منشقه ومجموعه صغيره ده
ده كلام مقاله يعني بتاع مقاله واخونا
جبرين بيعرف تماما انه مين القاعد دي الان
الموجودين في الميدان دي بيعرفنا كويس
وحنا كنا راس الحرب في الجبهه الثوريه ك
اسال جبريل ده ق له انتوا اسي انتم كعدل
ومساواه ان احنا زمان في الجبهه الثوريه
دي ان احنا اللي كنا بنقات وكنا بنسوق
الاخرين وحلفائنا الاخرين اللي بنسوق
وبنقل ق لهم بعد ان احنا ما عملنا المؤتمر
الاستثنائي هم الان لحد الليله العدل
والمساواه ما ضربت طلقه لحد الان هو اذا
بيتكلم عن جيش وبيتكلم عن قوه وبيتكلم عن
اصل لحد الان لم تستطع حركه العدل
والمساواه اللي بيتحدث باسمها جبريل لحد
الان ما ضربت طلقه في دارفور فلذلك الكلام
عن اصول وفروع كلام يعني غير صحيح احنا
الان موجودين بشهاده اليونت موجودين
بشهاده المواطني دارفور بيعرفوه تمام
موجودين بشهاده الاطراف الاخرى اللي بتحمل
السلاح بيعرفوه تماما وموجودين ومنتشر
الان انا داير اسال سؤال بسيط لاخونا
جبريل هم موجودين وين اذا هم بيتكلموا عن
انهم هم الاصل وعن انهم هم العدل
والمساواه هم غير موجودين الان في
دارفور غير موجودين والعدل والمساواه
مساله انه الناس اللي قاعدين في دي الناس
قادمين كلام غير صحيح طبعا احنا عندنا
تاريخ موجود يعني واضح سي سيد بشار حت حتى
لا
ندخل
موقفكم
الرافض وايضا اذا ما اخذها في الاعتبار
ادبيات السياسيه الا ترون ان فيها الكثير
من المفارقه والتناقض انتم من
جهه يعني تبدون ملاحظات على اتفاق السلام
وكانكم تعطون الانطباع بانكم حركه اصلاحيه
وفي نفس الوقت يعني بناء على ادبيات
السياسيه ومواقفكم المعروفه انتم تدعون
صراحه الى اسقاط النظام يعني في موقف
راديكالي كيف كيف يمكن فهم هذه
المفارقه طبعا ال موقف حركه العدل لمستواه
السودانيه الداعي للتسويه السياسيه هو
موقف مسجل ومعروف منذ ان انطلقت اول
مفاوضات مع حكومه السودان وكان الاتحاد
الافريقي شاهد على هذا الموقف والان
الجامعه العربيه والوساطه القطريه والوسيط
المشترك كلهم شهود على موقف حركه العدل
وال المساواه السودانيه الداعي الى مخاطبه
القضايا الرئيسيه عن طريق الحوار وعن طريق
التفاوض وحركه العدل المستوا السودانيه لم
ترفع السلاح الا عندما وصلت الى قناعه انه
حكومه السودان حكومه المؤتمر الوطني وعلى
لسان الرئيس البشير انه هم لا يخاطبون ولا
يتحدثون ولا يجلسون الا مع من يحمل السلاح
وحينها وجدت حركه العدل المس السودانيه
الطريق السياسي امامها مقفول ولذلك حملنا
السلاح ولم نحمل السلاح من من باب مواصله
الحرب او من باب الحروب التي لا طائل منها
بقدر ما انه رفعنا سلاح من اجل قضايا
معروفه وقضايا مشهوده وهذه القضايا اذا لم
تخاطب بصوره جذريه ما اعتقد انه سيكون
هنالك اي حلول سياسيه
تض مواقفكم هذه سيد جبريل الا تضعكم
مواقفكم هذه هذا الرفض الدائم في
يعني موقف الانعزال او او العزله عن عن
حراك حرك السلام الحاصل الان في في
المنطقه انظر مثلا المواقف الاخيره للنظام
السوداني اطلاق الحوار الوطني اطلاق
المعتقلين السياسيين الا يوفر هذا بئه
حاضنه
للسلام
والتوافق يا اخي العزيز اشكاليه المؤتمر
الطني النظام الحاكم في السودان هي اطلاق
المبادرات هي صناعه الازمات ثم حل هذه
الازمه المصطنعه ثم الحديث عن ان هنالك
انفراج حدث كيف يعقل لنظام المؤتمر الوطني
ان يلقي القبض على سبعه من القوه السياسيه
ويحدث ازمه بالقاء القبض على هؤلاء الناس
ثم يتخذ الرئيس البشير قرار في البرلمان
ويطلق صراح هؤلاء الناس ثم يحتفلون
بالحريات العامه يعني هذه مساله لا يمكن
ان تعقل حركه العدل المستوا السودانيه
صحيح الان بعد ما وصلت لقناعه ان الحوار
مع المؤتمر الوطني العمل السياسي مع
المؤتمر الوطني النظام الحاكم لا يؤدي الا
الى زياده عمر النظام ولا يؤدي الى الا
الى المزيد من الانشقاقات والمزيد من من
ضعف قوى الهامش وضعف القضيه السودانيه
سواء كان في دارفور في النيل الازرق غيره
لا يؤدي هذا الحوار الا لاطاله امد الحرب
في دارفور لا يؤدي الى الى انشاء حرب اخرى
في جبال النوبه في النيل الازرق لذ
احنا جلسنا مع باقي القوى السياسيه
السودانيه سواء كانت السياسيه وقوى الجبهه
الثوريه وتوصلنا لانه الخيار الوحيد الان
هو اسقاط نظام المؤتمر الوطني وازلام
المؤتمر الوطني واتباع المؤتمر الوطني فقط
بقي لي سؤال الى سيد بشار يعني هذا هذا
هذا التوقيع متزامن مع مؤتمر المانحين كيف
يمكن هذا العامل يعني عنصر مشجع على يعني
دعوه الاخرين للالتحاق ب هذه الاتفاقيه
طالما ان المساله هي مساله تنمويه بالاساس
يعني قضايا دارفور هي قضايا تنمويه
باختصار سيد بشار لو
سمحت نعم حقيقه المؤتمر اوول الاتفاق اللي
وقعته حركه العدل والمساواه مع الحكومه
السودانيه احنا بنفتكر انه فاتحه شهيه ل
للمانحين في انهم يمول مشروعات التنميه في
دارفور ونعتقد ايضا انه القضيه الاساسيه
في
دارفور الدوافع اللي شكلت ارادتنا لحمله
السلاح هي في الاساس يعني الدوافع خاصه
بالتنميه خاصه بالاعمار خاصه
بال سيد بشار انا انا اسف لان الوقت لان
الوقت انتهى ولكن الفكره بمجملها قد تكون
وصلت اشكرك سيد علي وافي بشار الناطق
الرسمي باسم حركه العدل والمساواه
السودانيه كنت معنا من الدوحه ومن لندن
جبريل ادم بلال الناطق باسم حركه العدل
والمساواه بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج موار الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في م وراء خبر جديد دمتم
[موسيقى]
بخير